vous avez vu cette histoire 135 euros
d'amendé pour les parents qui veulent
retirer leurs enfants de l'école avant
les vacances c'est aux enfants c'est un
bonne idée
vous êtes devenus autonomes et se
régaler mais vous vous êtes devenu ici
ben ça très bonne idée c'est
indispensable ça fait partie de
l'adaptation des jeunes à la citoyenneté
donc on n'est pas à l'école on a une
amende tout à fait normal bravo
ça fait rigoler il a raison eduardo
sortie series et l'école encore qui est
qui va qui va capter la produit que la
directrice c'est qui qui va aller voir
les policiers en dix ans madame michu
eux n'est pas venu parce que le petit à
petit et au moins jusqu'à 13 heures
[Musique]
on peut simplement
simplement responsabiliser les parents
en leur disant on compte sur vous pour
garder les enfants jusqu'au terme à
l'école on n'est pas obligé de menacer
avec une sanction financière
mais la raison valérie les cas ça doit
être c'est un sanctuaire gilles il faut
pas commencer à appliquer les profs doit
pas se transformer en flic pas donc
c'est ridicule à cheval j'ai surtout
parce que là il a offert jamais alors
eduardo keqin on joue j'aime beaucoup je
vous je vous aime beaucoup mais aussi
celle ci jamais vraiment ça me fait
râler c'est un petit sms de ma par avoir
françois hollande a alors que la marche
réussie ou non mais je voudrais quand
même dire quelque chose on débat
beaucoup on est un pays très politique
très débatteurs très critiquée c'est
l'esprit français que nous aimons tous
mais quand même on pourrait de temps en
temps juste prendre un tout petit peu de
recul et de regarder ce que font les
gens de l'école de la république pour
quand même accueillir nos enfants malgré
la crise du coville de ses nombreux mois
je pense que vraiment ça fait du bien de
pouvoir on a tous senti quand on les
parents c'est mon cas c'est le cas de
beaucoup d'entre vous c'est vrai qu'au
d'hilarité les professeurs les
enseignants en dehors du convient
d'ailleurs mais là avec le co vide quand
même moi je constate je crois que c'est
pas le cas partout qu'on a une belle
école de la république qui a réussi à
s'organiser pour continuer cette chose
fondamentale qui est l'enseignement
l'inscription la continuité de l'école
malgré locaux vides et on sait que ça a
été difficile doit nous pour vous n'êtes
pas candidat de la gauche où je
comprends pas à la fête quoi l'on a mais
moi je travaille et puis je suis
toujours engagé en politique je pense
que j'aurai avec le ps toujours avec le
parti si je suis très inquiet ça et
cyril parce que moi j'ai beaucoup de
légèreté et ses hommes c'est vrai on est
dans une période et mon père les repères
ses comptes en n'importe quoi je vais te
dire un truc ayant fait deux trois
choses en place mais il a raison parce
que hier on disait un truc de
franchement on en rigolait etc mais là
c'est bien vous soyez là c'est vrai que
ça nous fait de la peine de voir aussi
le parti socialiste aussi bas dans les
sondages c'est vrai qu'on aurait on voit
beaucoup beaucoup de partis extrêmes qui
sont extrêmement on a l'impression c'est
vrai qu'il ya un basculement dont on
parle un peu plus sérieusement c'est
vrai mais je suis un peu d'accord avec
eduardo
les limites ça nous fait de la peine
série de voir le ps à 3% ça c'est
incroyable c'est difficile mais il faut
pas perdre espoir c'est une situation
sans ratures et vous savez la gauche
c'est pas simplement un parti où des
partis moi je dis toujours la gauche
elle est dans le coeur des gens
dans le coeur des gens qui se sentent de
gauche et c'est cet espoir la séquence
est difficile que la gauche bien au
rendez vous moi je veux croire que c'est
possible je veux croire qu' il ya des
rassemblements encore possible et je
veux surtout dire aux gens ne perdez pas
espoir il faut continuer de se battre et
je n'aime pas ce ton parfois de
moqueries on a sur les partis politiques
en général moi je voudrais que ça nuit à
la politique mais c'est par amour on est
tous je veux dire parfois d'ailleurs les
politiques le cher mais je crois qu'il
faut faire attention à pas moqué les
partis politiques au point de penser
quiconque on pourrait s'en passer